هذه المعركة البطولية تضم 16 مقاتلاً في شقة واحدة
في بيت حانون، نحن هنا للمرة الأولى وبطريقة ما
لدي أكثر من 50 دقيقة من الصور والتسجيلات
من مصادر مختلفة أقف على م
الأخ لا
ابني ليس على بعد قدم من هناك كما أرى
حدوث نزيف في اليدين والرجلين
لا أعرف ماذا أضع عليه
قم بتوجيه الكاميرا الأولى إلى أنف دفير المصاب
أصعب شيء هو أنك لا تتوقف عن التسجيل للحظة
ليس لدي غطاء
ليس لدي يد
ياد أفهم أن شيطانًا من روس قال إنني موجود في المنطقة
البحر الخطير الذي تصرخ به يداك تنظر إلى اليسار
في تلك اللحظة أفهم أنه لن يكون هناك أحد هناك
ساعدني، لقد اختطفنا صاروخًا، أرى دفير
في عيني أفهم أن وضعه صعب وأنا لست كذلك
اعتقدت أنه سينجو من هذا الشعور
بأنني سأموت لأننا جميعاً نموت
توجد كاميرتان إضافيتان للشركة في الطوابق
الملابس الداخلية التي تسجل إقالتنا، الجملة قد انتهت بالفعل
الاول
ضرب
وبعد ذلك تركني الكثير من الأشخاص في الشركة
لقد انقطعت للأسف في معركة الإنقاذ هذه
من فريق الطباشير في غرفة المعيشة، انهار ثلاثة مقاتلين
سقطت رينو من الطابق الثالث وأصيبت بجروح خطيرة
يفوز بدرج إيليا بالشظايا في كل مكان
يحصل الجسم المثقوب بالبار على غرفة مجاورة لغرفة معيشة Kedo
المسعف وقائد الفريق هما الوحيدان اللذان قاما بإخماد الحريق
للإرهابي
ديرا سيطلب له المروحية
مثل أين المروحية لأنني قلت أنها الآن
الآن لا بد لي من ركوب المروحية وإلا
التراب الذهبي
اليش تعال معي واحد معي واحد معي واحد
إحدى الجزر للإخلاء، شنقتك ود
نحن لا نهتم حتى إذا أطلقوا النار علينا مرة أخرى
هنا